this morning the new push for fusion
energy a cleaner safer form of nuclear
energy has long been a goal there have
been unrealistic hopes and promises for
decades
but slowly progress is being made
to get an up-close look we traveled to
princeton new jersey to see what life is
like
at 200 million
degrees what tunnel are we in
so we're in the tunnel it leads from the
control room to the machine itself
inside an experimental laboratory at
princeton university
underneath a nondescript building
stephen cowley took us down the long
corridor that leads to his life's work
all these are sub-systems of the machine
an attempt to recreate the energy
in the middle of the sun it's really the
perfect energy source
fusion when atomic nuclei come together
takes place in the heart of stars
it's the opposite of fission when nuclei
break apart
fission is how nuclear power plants work
also nuclear bombs
a million tons of water alive with
deadly rays
fusion has been science's holy energy
grail for the last century
the fits and starts have led to plenty
of frustration the perfect energy source
is one that doesn't take up much space
has a virtually inexhaustible supply
is safe
it's fusion you gave a ted talk in 2009
you said fusion by 2030
we're eight years away this is the
problem with the modern age with video
isn't it
[Laughter]
right there you keep submitting to
interviews here
yeah i mean i think that we are looking
now so the national academy of sciences
has come forward to say we want to start
actually producing electricity by 2035.
i was close
okay but we're still that's still not a
guarantee that's a yeah it's a hope
yeah
hope is closer to reality when you take
a look
at a tokamak
there it is
that's it that's the machine right there
and if you look you can see
the red things are coiled
inside a tokamak temperatures can reach
up to 200 million degrees when there's
no such thing as solids liquids or gas
it's all plasma when you look at the
eruptions from the sun you know there's
pictures you see of
solar flares erupting from the sun
that's actually plasma forcing its way
through a magnetic field and out and
we're trying to do
that here we're not trying to let it
erupt we're trying to control it to hold
it down
what's happening on the sun happens oh
absolutely right here right inside there
right now experimental machines like
these are only able to sustain fusion at
target temperatures
for a few seconds
and the goal is to have that sustained
yeah for hours hours days months yes
once they can do that they'll be able to
use that heat to make steam which
eventually makes electricity
simple simple yeah
is this a dangerous business
one of the great advantages of fusion is
that there are no
bad case safety issues with it
so it can't melt down
it doesn't have a you know a big an
explosive potential or anything else
like that so it's a very safe energy
source that you could put next to your
town
that's a that's a big advantage
cowley believes our long-term energy
future is a combination of renewables
like wind and solar
and fusion the obvious advantage of
fusion is that you don't need sun or
wind to get the job done
a few gallons of seawater and the
lithium in a couple of laptop batteries
could provide enough energy for one
person
for their entire life
is it a money issue right now there's
always a money issue but actually what
we really need to do is to drive the
innovation it's ideas
bright scientists
coming into the field and solving the
remaining problems i think we can do
fusion
our big challenge at the moment is to do
it at a cost that the consumer wants to
pay for their electricity
yeah it's not free it does cost it costs
money to do all this research and that
will cost money to buy the energy but
think about that for a second the energy
in a few gallons of seawater yeah and a
couple laptop batteries could power your
life your entire life
unbelievable a plus on explaining it to
us
making sense absolutely and the idea
that they can do it you just need to do
it for this extended period of time so
that you can have enough steam to create
the energy but the best part of this is
the potential for it maybe not to be
free but low cost yeah well that's i
mean people aren't going to do it if
it's if it's super expensive maybe not
in our maybe in our lifetimes but
certainly we hope in our kids left we
have hope it reminds me of the saint
that movie
cold fusion base anyway i haven't seen
that in a while never mind that fell
kill me no we're gonna thank you jeff